what's your mission what's your goal um
what's my goal personally
or with the proud boys you said you
don't want to sit back and do nothing
something a lot of people don't know is
that most proud boys
aren't activists most of them don't go
to rallies most of them
the only like activism i guess that they
do is go out to vote
um there's a small percentage of proud
boys that are politically active like
myself
i've been doing uh i've been active for
18 years i was a canvasser i was a
campaign manager
door knocker i've worked the polls
and it's always something that i've been
passionate about so
our goals are simple um we we think
about
the entire organization and basically
what we want to do
is just make better men in general
better brothers better husbands
better fathers um
everything else after that is auxiliary
right
um and i think we focus on more the
celebratory aspect of the west
instead of the defend aspect of the west
but we do we do do both
right so let me let me ask you the very
um in my opinion i can't stand the
question but
we'll do it anyway will will you right
now denounce white supremacy
no no i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm
kidding
so check this out yeah that's it that's
that's what they're gonna pick up right
now okay so
not that unequivocally and and
and i've said this before i denounce
white supremacy
i denounce anti-semitism i denounce
fascism i denounce communism i denounce
antifa i denounce
any other ism right that is prejudice
against people because of the color of
their skin
because of their religion because of
their cultural background and any
anything that has to do with
authoritarian governments um
and i hate having to repeat that so many
times and i know that there's a lot of
viewers here that don't know who the
proud boys is
but i have to constantly repeat that i
don't like labeling myself
and this is the the afro cuban label is
something that that the media uses all
the time
and i hate putting people in boxes
people shouldn't be put in boxes
um yeah like people say oh well how
could they be
racist and here look i'll be clear about
that how could they be racist if they
have a brown chairman
well you could you could be any color
and be racist
but i am not racist the organization is
not racist we don't care
i just i just really need to point out
how stupid our current media ecosystem
is that i have to ask a black man if
he's a white supremacist yeah
so i i recognize the absurdity of the
question for all the people in the
audience i think it's stupid
but that's like i think people who are
like regular moderate americans and
conservatives
roll their eyes when they constantly
hear questions like that but you have
this institution this news institutions
these news institutions that genuinely
don't know or don't
care and so you you have to sort of
have a question like that in a sense to
make sure it's absolutely
and and you know positively clear as
absurd and stupid as it is
it's also kind of incomplete because
it's like do you denounce racial
supremacy
yes yeah of course together period and
that should be the argument not white
not black supremacy not
native american supremacy not jewish
supremacy it's all bad stuff
being a racial supremacist is a bad
thing yeah
well so let me ask you about that shirt
okay american supremacist i have here
the merriam-webster dick uh
merriam-webster
dictionary definition of fascism they
say
a political philosophy movement or
regime such as that of the fascisti
that exalts nation and often race above
the individual
and that stands for a centralized
autocratic government headed by a
dictatorial leader
severe economic and social regimentation
and forcible suppression
of opposition so um i think you've
already explained this
i think the only thing out of that is
that you uh
are a patriot but would you so clearly
let me just ask you are you for a
centralized autocratic
government absolutely not are you in
favor of putting the race above the
individual
no uh are you in favor of a dictatorial
leader
nope social or economic regimentation
nope or forcible suppression of your
opposition
nope do you believe that antifa should
be allowed to go out and protest so long
as they don't get violent
yes do you think that the nation should
be exalted above the individual
no well i think the individual i think
the individual the reason why i'm an
american supremacist is
because the founding of this country
is about the individual it's about your
individual liberties uh
the founding fathers didn't envision
this this
powerhouse they didn't this isn't what
they wanted per se
it's beautiful that we have it but they
just wanted
to build a nation that was free that you
have your plot of land
you could practice your religion you
could have your family you can
you can raise them however you want
and be free of of
basically to do whatever it is that you
want right
and the federal government was built to
protect that from foreign invaders and
we've gotten so far
past that it was it was about the
individual we got
um and it's funny because
the revolution was started at the
basement of a bar
and the american revolution the american
revolution was started at the basement
of a bar
and a bunch of farmers and carpenters
and
and just regular joes faced off against
the biggest superpower that the world
has seen to that time
and they won and they were tired of it
and they didn't want that
so when the president says i agree with
the president when the president says
law and order
i agree with him because i understand
where he's coming from he says law and
order in these cities that don't have
law and order
too much law and order is bad you know
legislators get elected by proposing
new legislation new laws they don't get
elected by deregulating
and i think that's that's a major
problem that we have and we're so far
from that
you know free speech you know okay yeah
the government isn't stopping us from
from speaking our words but now the
corporations are
so let me uh i'm gonna pull up the
anti-defamation league
and i'm gonna show you i'm gonna i'm
gonna read what they say about your
organization in fact they use a photo of
you
in the proud voice it says uh they don't
say your name i don't think i'm gonna
read what they say about you and some of
their
criticism is it a good photo uh
yeah you look very serious yeah you the
you're you're shaving but you have the
goatee going on
they say your ideology is primarily alt
light misogynistic islamophobic
transphobic and anti-immigration some
members espouse white supremacists and
anti-semitic ideologies and or engage
with white supremacist groups
so the first question is you don't allow
women into your organization
we do not we have an organization that's
for women
what's that organization proud boys
girls all right yep so they say you're
misogynists
i i don't have right i think we can get
into what they actually write down
actually let me do this because they
don't actually uh present anything in
that gen
generalization but here's the background
the proud boys represent an
unconventional strain of american
right-wing extremism
while the group can be described as
violent nationalistic islamophobic
transphobic and misogynist misogynistic
its members represent a range of ethnic
backgrounds and its leaders vehemently
protest any allegations of racism their
founder gavin mcinnis went so far as to
file a defamation lawsuit against the
southern poverty law center
when the splc designated the proud boys
a hate group
so they they do point out you have uh
various backgrounds but they call you
violent nationalistic islamophobic
transphobic and
misogynistic so i don't know if you
wanna have a
direct response to you know what they're
saying there and they'll ask you some
questions
okay so um i mean there's a lot of like
a lot of words there to dispel but um
again it's like a repetitive answer we
don't
care what somebody's race is we don't
care what somebody's religion is
are jokes crude yes uh
we joke about all kinds of things we
joke about
we joke about races we joke i make fun
of myself
i make fun of the white dudes i always
call the the
like i said earlier like in my chapter
white is a minority
so but there's not there's not like this
level of seriousness with us
and i said we don't take ourselves
seriously we take what we do seriously i
take what i do seriously
but we don't take ourselves serious
enough where we're not laughing
um where we're
constantly on i feel like we've been put
on like this defense
i just came from amp fest um in miami
and like all the speakers are talking
about how uh
how we should be on how the left is
doing this how the left is encroaching
on things and how
we're not racist we're not racist we're
not i'm tired of that
like we in 2016 we were
we were funny we were on the offense and
i feel like
right now getting labeled everything by
by the adl by the splc which is is a
money mill
you know they started out i'm not even
gonna say uh
i believe this wholeheartedly but they
were started out with good intention
uh to do away with the ku klux klan
right and they did and as the world got
more and more peaceful
there was less and less boogeymen and
less and less enemies
to to grift off of so what do they have
to do they have to create these enemies
right we're not islamophobic we're not
homophobic we're not transphobic we're
not any of that
they were trying to uh they were trying
to
i guess make fun of us i didn't i don't
know if you saw that like the
the pictures they put prod voice hashtag
and they had like two dudes oh right
right yes i did right i actually i i
called that out as an a really good
example of the left not understanding
what the wright is actually talking
about or doing
yeah and i put up a picture of like
gavin making out with rhino
i don't know if you saw that yeah and uh
i put that and i put hashtag proud boys
and they thought they thought oh oh
proud boys are furious about it
yeah obviously they have not infiltrated
our chats
because if they would they'd be like oh
well this is like
this is play school stuff this is this
is the problem we have the media
and they've you're you're joe biden made
you the chosen boogeyman
of you know these groups and then
they do the media no i think joe biden
oh why do you think him
because people that are going to vote
for biden are going to vote for biden no
matter what and they're not really
actually voting for biting they're
voting anti-trump right um there's no
energy there but whatever
that's my opinion trump supporters are
gonna vote for trump no matter what
but these people in the center that are
watching that are actually trying to
decide between one candidate or another
um this thing gets brought up we're
we're a bigger hit than covid when kovid
should be like one of the main things
that both candidates are talking about
um proud boys comes up in like a little
snippet
and it suddenly turns into to to date uh
he's
the biden camp has sent 14 ads
email ads for fundraising with proud
boys names on it white supremacy and
white supremacy
um well those people that are watching
to to figure out what side that
which person that they're going to vote
on they come up with proud boys and
they're like oh okay well these guys
must be bad
because biden just mentioned them well
when you go ahead and you google
and just on the surface i know that
there's like our
our wikipedia page is edited by antifa
um but you do just a little bit of
digging and they'll understand who we
are plus
um and i'll say this i think first on
your show
uh i have 160 guys in my chapter
in my south florida chapter i have 345
which is the last time i checked 345
applications
to join my chapter alone and that is
something that has
expanded across the country it's the
same thing all over the place where they
have more people in vetting in the
vetting process
than they do in their chapter he's has
grown our numbers exponentially you're
saying joe biden
has grown your numbers by and and i
think they're happy too
i think joe biden is very happy that to
hear that yeah uh well
he's probably fundraising uh he wants a
lot of money well he wants a boogeyman
yeah right i need one i'm i'm pretty
sure there's a lot of people who've been
young in the comments
because you know i've been asking a lot
of these questions and
you know giving some some some critique
and pushback and i'm sure there's much
been on the left who are saying i'm not
nearly
hard enough but the i think obviously
the media the way they frame what the
proud boys
are who you are is very clearly
fake news i think when i look at the end
of defamation league they got a bunch of
citations and sources for various proud
boys and so i'll get into that
i think they're taking a left critical
view of you some some of these things
like transphobic for instance
i think it's fair to say there are uh
from a left perspective there are
probably a lot of instances
where they could call you a transphobic
my bathroom
uh at my office has a has a piece of
artwork from sabo
that has like half man half woman that
says it
right well you guys do it as a joke do i
treat
uh people that are uh transgender
different
no i don't do i like joking about things
yes
of course but at the end of the day it's
what your actions are not what your
words are
unless they're words unless they're like
very strong words like i
i say something because you're trans you
get me
i don't do that and my guys don't do
that
well there there are certain people
proud boys
uh they're a little spicier than normal
yeah you can't control them
you know they'll go on tv or they'll be
at a park or they'll say something
and that reflects on all of you of
course that's as a group
yes it's it's it's probably as
you know you could run pr for one person
it's very easy
but running a pr for an entire group you
know is scary
but let me tell you something uh
we're not what the media describes us as
uh
i have the best group of guys that i
have ever met okay
and i have never myself the only time
that i've experienced like racism is
when somebody drops the n-bomb on me
uh from the other side or calls me a
[ __ ]
or calls me uncle tom i've seen my guys
my guys yeah my guys have never even
like
referred to me anywhere close to what
what they have
yes are we crude are we everybody's cup
of tea absolutely not
we cuss like sailors and it's taking
everything inside of me not to cuss
right now thank you um uh i was in
portland
and i saw a black proud boy and antifa
was screaming the n-word
and other words at him and it was just
like shockingly gratuitous
and he snapped he snapped he pulled away
from the group
of the trump supporters who were
marching and he went to cross the street
through the police line
and i saw another proud boy run up grab
him hug him
put his forward to him and said don't
let them get to you we're brothers
races doesn't matter you're here with us
ignore them i was i gotta say it was
shocking to hear the racial slurs being
spouted by antifa there's video of it
actually
where uh i'm pretty sure i have that
video published on my channel somewhere
i've too many videos but there's also a
video of antifa in portland screaming
the n-word and racial slurs at uh ice
agents
so i've seen that and i've wondered why
it is the media doesn't call that out
specifically because
for all the criticism anyone or i could
give to the proud boys that's a
criticism that needs to be said of
antifa
and and these other left extremists
wouldn't that video
wouldn't those videos because i have i
have videos like that
wouldn't those videos put them on the
splc's radar
because the splc says that we haven't
classified antifa because they are not
they don't discriminate based on race
but here we are
i have a whole bunch of those videos you
said that you have some and i know my
guys have a whole bunch
oh yeah um i think i get i get called
uncle tom all the time
no but i i i understand that the left
doesn't take
you know issue with that racial slur of
course not but no they were saying the
n-word they were screaming it yeah and i
was just like
i was standing there like i knew these
people were nasty but that was like
they wanted a fight they wanted to fight
and they wanted to trigger this guy
and it almost worked and uh man i
couldn't believe it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time